can you talk about how the outer journey
and the inner journey are combined
within this six plot structure yeah I
mean they definitely intertwine again as
I said earlier you can have a story
that's all outer journey
it's just plot it's the character doing
whatever physically is needed to achieve
that visible goal and there's enough
conflict from the visible obstacles from
nature and other characters that we
don't need to go deeper in the character
but if you choose as a writer to go to
that inner journey level to explore the
inner conflict within the hero to see
the tug-of-war between identity in
essence between living a false persona
and living a characters truth and living
in a fearful state but protected state
versus living courageously if you want
to explore that
then they'll intertwined because as I
said the rule is the closer they get to
achieving the goal the more they have to
be moving toward their essence it's it's
called an art because it arcs over the
whole story and every time their fear
takes over they have to lose ground so
to speak it keeps them from achieving
the goal so in a love story this is easy
to see because if the characters are in
conflict the hero and what I call the
romance character the love interest if
they're arguing it means one of them is
in his or her identity and it's stopping
them from getting more intimate if
they're both in their essence they're
going to grow closer and become more
intimate that's why the midpoint that
point of no-return represents a bigger
commitment is oftentimes the first time
they make love because it's physical
intimacy that matches the emotional
intimacy they have from opening up and
showing each other their essence showing
each other their truth so that arc for
the hero is going to correspond to the
hero getting closer and closer to the
outer motivation but there's another
cool way that they can intertwine and a
good tool that you can use as a
screenwriter or as a novelist or
filmmaker of any kind
even an actor because this will inform
your performance and that is to look at
some other key characters in the story
one is a character I term the reflection
the reflection is my term for the
sidekick for the character who's most
closely aligned with the hero so it
might be a best friend it might be a
co-worker it might be a mentor like mr.
Miyagi and Karate Kid or if it's the new
Karate Kid mr. Han or Obi Wan or just
anyone who is there to support the hero
who's aligned with the hero at the
beginning of the story so in gravity for
example Ryan the Sandra Bullock
character is the hero of that movie but
is closely aligned with and supported by
the George Clooney character now on the
visible journey level on the plot level
that reflection character is the
reflection because their job is to help
the hero achieve her visible goal so in
gravity what's your visible goal to get
back to earth who's the character who's
going to help her do that more than
anyone it's George Clooney's character I
wish I could remember that character's
name but I don't okay but once you have
that character functioning as a
reflection on the outer journey now you
can see how you use them on the inner
journey level and on the inner journey
level the reflection is the character
who reveals the hero's essence to the
hero or another way to say it is the
reflection is the character who holds
the hero's feet to the fire and anytime
they're retreating into their identity
the reflection will say what are you
doing this isn't you you should be going
after that person or you can't give up
there are numerous moments in gravity
where the George Clooney character first
is a real person and then as a figment
of her imagination says you don't want
to give up I know why you want to give
up it's terrible it's terrifying but if
you can find the courage and you can put
one foot in front of the other
keep living your life that's the way you
want to be and that's a typical scene or
situation for a reflection character
donkey does that for Shrek the Vince
Vaughn character and wedding crashers
does it for Owen Wilson so Owen Wilson
has retreated after they broke up into
his identity and now he's crashing
funerals as well as weddings and then
Swan cousin says why are you doing this
you got to go after her she's going to
get married she's marrying the wrong guy
you love her and so that reflection
character can intertwine on the inner
journey because they're sort of pushing
the hero toward their essence and the
other character that also becomes a
valuable tool if you're writing a love
story which is a great genre it's a
great tool when you want to explore
inner the inner life of the character to
add a love story to your plot whatever
the genre is it's what I call the
romance character the love interest
because on the visible goal level if
it's a love story the hero's visible
goal has to include winning the love of
that other character they want to end up
in a committed relationship with that
person they may do it reluctantly they
may be blind to it at first but
eventually by the midpoint anyway
they're going to declare their love in
some way and they're going to actively
pursue that person romantically but on
the inner journey level the way that
works is the the love interest is the
reward for the hero having found the
courage to be in his essence so again
you can't win true up you can't you
can't win the love of another character
if you're living a false life you have
to be in your essence and so with love
stories the way it works is if you're
writing a love story to avoid the
mistake of having these two people be
together just because you want them to
be for no logical reason other than
they're both good-looking and they're
the co-stars of the movie if you want it
to really make logical sense and really
have your audience respond to it
emotionally then the romance character
is the character who sees beneath the
heroes identity
they connect at the level of essence and
so anytime they're in conflict their
identity is coming into play when they
actually connect their @s they're at the
level of essence and nobody else that
the hero is ever falling for or is
involved with or in love with at the
beginning of the movie none of them see
the hero's essence only the true love
can do that and so now that level of
plot is also intertwined with the inner
journey as well can we talk about though
a friend who then becomes an enemy or
has been an enemy all along or vice
versa
someone that we thought was an enemy an
opponent but was actually more
benevolent than we imagined during the
beginning of the movie
yeah because I use these terms in this
jargon I've created like hero nemesis
romance reflection the Nemesis is the
villain by the way or the opponent
because I use those terms often that
question will come up well what if a
character starts out as a reflection a
best friend and turns out to actually be
the killer and then become the nemesis I
recommend that a writer not look at it
that way I recommend that you use the
terms that you would apply at the end of
Act one how is the how is this character
established at the beginning in the
beginning act of your script so if this
is the character who's the best friend
who's aligned with the hero then they
remain the reflection throughout the
movie they just become a reflection who
turns out to be a bad guy or a killer or
a murderer or or a spy or whatever it
turns out that they are and if a
character starts out to be a friend but
then this is about the two of them
falling in love and we know that's where
it's headed
then it's the romance character from the
get-go and there might be another best
friend to be a reflection and so on the
nemesis who turns out to be a good guy
that can happen as well but it's done
slightly differently it's not so much
that the nemesis has been hiding the
fact that he's a good guy as much as he
has a change of heart and realizes I'm
going after the wrong thing I got to
help
hero Tommy Lee Jones in the fugitive
would be that kind of Nemesis he's in
opposition to the hero but finally he
reaches a point where he realizes I'm
going after the wrong guy and I've got
to help him find the truth so I don't
think it's wise to think about
characters changing category because it
just becomes too complicated and my goal
among many others is to make the process
as simple as possible
I mean screenwriting is tough enough
without making it more complicated than
it is so I like to use these terms for
introducing characters and how they're
going to function overall and not start
switching categories
you